e
eu venho aqui para te falar de uma
organização que não é uma organização
muito conhecida que os alguma maneira a
ganhou uma grande relevância no ano
passado a e vou fazê-lo de uma maneira
que não tem interesse nenhum para a
organização e para a organização é uma
coisa que perfeitamente
fora do tema que é a história da minha
vida na realidade eu trabalhei na
organização transcendente como qualquer
funcionário da organização mas isto
marcou e foi uma decisão que alterou
completamente a aquilo que eu pensava e
aquilo que eu gostava de fazer bem a
minha vida começou mais ou menos quando
eu tinha 5 anos e meu pai me deu um
estojinho com aquele rosto gente química
que e divertidíssima fazer coisas com
enxofre e
por a casa toda a cheirando a um cheiro
de horrorosos e tentar correr atrás das
minhas tias e das da minha avó com
aquele cheiro de maneira que elas
ficavam agoniada cê compunham para fora
fazer coisas com korze outras coisas e
se passou até que mais tarde eu entrei
para a faculdade aqui para a FCT a onde
podem ver ali algumas caras conhecidas
principalmente umas barbas naquela
altura pretas ali no meio ou já não
estão daquela cor e isto foi o primeiro
ano da FCT o curso de química aplicada
aqui na ST foi interessantíssimo Adorei
e
como este curso aqui desporto
Principalmente uma grande capacidade em
mim capacidade de pensar eu nunca fui
boa aluna porque eu gostava muito de ir
para a praia de ir para as festas e
portanto não tinha assim a briga muito
curiosa mas o que um grande grande banco
esta que esta Universidade tendo em mim
foi abrir me abrir um bocadinho a minha
cabeça para a capacidade de pensar mas
este voltando a minha história de
crescer química e de cortar de ser
química e gostar de ser cientista e
querer ganhar o prêmio Nobel eu recebi
foi para o laboratório e trabalhei
durante muitos anos no laboratório fazia
investigação e desenvolvimento no
laboratório do ineti mas não me sentia
francamente feliz de vos dizer era era
muito interessante o trabalho
mas eu não via o impacto deste trabalho
na benesse no melhoria da vida das
outras pessoas e eu comecei a sentir que
havia de fazer alguma coisa nessa altura
comecei por me interessar pela segurança
em química segurança em laboratórios
passei depois é uma fase seguinte que
era a fase de resposta à emergência
E aí a Proteção Civil e a partir daí
entrei em contacto com esta organização
sim permitem eu não vou dizer o nome é
português que é o PAC Mas quem inglês
chama ou pcw e eu não porque é mais
conhecida e a entrei em contacto com
esta missão que é organização
responsável pela implementação da
convenção para a proibição das armas
químicas mas o que é isto e o que é o
PAC bem alpaca É como diz o meu diretor
geral lá para trás no tempo é uma
organização que fundamento desconhecida
da grande maior parte das pessoas é tão
das pessoas como é dos media ninguém os
media sabe quem é normalmente dizem que
nós somos uma organização ou frescura
minúscula e até um bocadinho nerds e eu
estou completamente aceitar as palavras
do meu diretor geral também somos porque
normalmente qualificados com altamente
profissionais e muito eficientes somos
tão eficientes que E desde que
organização foi criada
1997 conseguimos já e em termos de
Tratado de não-proliferação e
desarmamento sermos o tratado que mais
bem-sucedido temos 190 países que são
estados partes da organização e Já
conseguimos até agora destruindo oitenta
e dois por cento os arsenais químicos
que existem número
é bem mas voltando à história da minha
vida
eu em Janeiro 2007 peguei nas malinhas
roménia Holanda e aí estava eu na
organização
Tô voltando outra vez um cadinho atrás e
aí como é que esta organização funciona
é o único tratado não
discriminatório e multilateral o que é
que significa é um único tratado de
desarmamento que na realidade trata os
países todos da mesma maneira todos os
países tem que destruir as armas
químicas Não importa se eles Estados
Unidos ou o valor a tu que eu tenho
sequer sabia que existia com país antes
nos juntar a organização ou Santa Luzia
EA China tá todos os países são tratados
por igual todos os países têm os mesmos
direitos de todos para isso tem os menos
muito de ver esta organização também tem
como meta e baseada nesta convenção que
vocês podem ver ali a uma uma uma
categoria inteira de armas de destruição
maciça as armas químicas
e eu optei por
e este eu optei por não trazer nenhuma
as fotografias e não por aqui umas
fotografias sobre a
vítimas de armas químicas e razão é
muito simples são imagens horríveis e
foi muito popular quando eu fui
convidada para esta palestra que a única
coisa que eu tinha que ser era positiva
pronto e eu achei que isso era demasiado
negativo e principalmente macia negativo
para começar o dia
portanto eu resolvi explicar diz o que é
que é destruição das armas químicas se
vocês quiserem poder ir à internet há
imensas imagens poderão ver o que é que
é o impacto destas árvores e tão
importante que a fazer esta distribuição
se vocês se lembrarem no dia 21 de
agosto em gota na Síria houve um ataque
com a gente estar em mais de 1.500
pessoas morreram e muitas outras ficaram
feridas e sofrem ainda hoje sobre o
efeito deste arma mortal EA razão é
porque quando a o quanto foram
quando a arma foi usada os agentes
primeira resposta os bombeiros dos
médicos que não estavam preparados para
tratar este tipo doentes e as tipo
doente chegaram ao hospital carregados
cheios nas suas roupas do agente
contaminante o agente tóxico pronto mas
não cumpriu ou não perder vamos voltar
aqui a a distribuição esta convenção
requer e aqui estão Os Quatros pilares
da convenção porque a destruição de
todos os mais armas químicas e sua
capacidade de produção como eu já vos
disse a até hoje foram destruídas
oitenta e dois por cento de todo o
Arsenal que existe ao mesmo tempo eu
posso vos dizer que a em relação às
armas químicas da Síria já só restam na
Síria oito por cento de todo o Arsenal
graças ao trabalho Fantástico que os
meus colegas estão a fazer lá neste
momento em condições extremamente
adversas como vocês podem imaginar
é mas esta convenção que tem mais outra
coisa aliás tem mais três coisas e
igualmente importante uma delas é a
verificação da não-proliferação ou seja
significa que químicos em todos os
sítios Nós estamos neste mês que
Acordamos de manhã e abrimos o lençol um
lençol está cheio de químicos vamos à
casa de banho levamos os dentes a pasta
dos dentes das sete químicos produtos
químicos existem em toda a nossa vida e
quanto e a função produzidos em todas as
indústrias que vocês possam imaginar mas
são usados para fins benéficos e para o
progresso da humanidade e é isso que
esta convenção pretende manter pretende
verificar que todos os químicos
produzidos os mais tóxicos outros menos
tóxicos são apenas usado para o bem da
humanidade
E
isto é uma outra parte que é feita
pronto esta parte é toda feita baseada
em declarações dos países eu não vou
entrar por aí porque vai ser era uma
grande chatice e toda a gente adormecia
nos próximos oito minutos e 45 que eu
tenho para falar mas vamos falar dos
dois outros pilares da convenção e que
são igualmente importante
estes dois pilares vocês podem imaginar
são aplicáveis o primeiro aí mais ou
menos a 10 países que tenham armas
químicas o segundo mais ou menos a 40 60
países mais industrializados Mas
voltando ao nosso vanuatu O que é que
interessava anula ato esta convenção mas
é importante que esta convenção chega a
universalidade portanto que todos os
países do mundo assina que só assim faz
sentido E para isso os arquitetos da
convenção escreveram mais dois quentes
artigos que se revelaram importantes uma
vez que são a cenoura na frente do burro
dos países para assinarem esta conta é
um deles é o apoio a cooperação
internacional para o desenvolvimento uso
Pacífico da química e significa que a
existe a organização apoia o
desenvolvimento da química em termos de
promover a projeto de investigação a dar
apoio a treino a treino
feito para os para os
utilizadores dos diversos países dos
laboratórios de investigação dos
diversos países e permite fazer um
desenvolvimento na área da cooperação
química também temos por exemplo de
Apoio às indústrias a pequenas
indústrias de pequenos países que depois
podem fazer estágios em grandes
indústrias dos países
Oi e da última mas não menos importante
e eu deixei para o fim porque foi aquela
onde eu trabalhei e é a área do meu
coração Ah e a área de assistência e
proteção e o que é isto Esta área de
assistência e proteção os países quando
assim não esta convenção tem o direito
de receber preparação para responderam a
um incidente com armas químicas e tem o
direito de receber apoio no caso de um a
gente que me ter sido usado no seu no
seu território
isto porque e se você disser sim mas
vocês vão destruir as armas químicas
todas muito rapidamente já sou a
dezoito por cento ou para que é que isto
tem interesse por voz que temos países o
que é importante não é um ataque com
armas químicas é um pequeno acidente com
o produto químico que eles tem guardado
num dos teus armazéns que que vai passar
as suas estradas dentro de um camião tir
portanto é necessário de alguma maneira
treinar os países
a treinar os países essa é a primeira
parte da primeira parte da proteção por
parte da preparação a parte dos o
treinamento dos países é feito como bem
primeiro temos que ensinar como vocês
sabem Com certeza já viram os bombeiros
usarem aqueles fatos completamente
fechados com respiração auxiliar essas
fotografias que vocês vão ver não tem os
fatos tem outro e fatos mas é exatamente
a mesma coisa Primeiro eles têm que
aprender a usar a máscara
e depois tem que aprender a usar o fato
e podem imaginar que estes fatos não são
propriamente a mesma coisa que usar um
fato de treino e correr na praia com uns
calções em biquíni a isto a partir de 20
graus começa a ser um autêntico sauna
E aí e aprendem a como fato tem que ser
estilo vocês podem ver por aqui pelas
fotografias a que um fato não é
propriamente de
uso fácil portanto nem a investir
facilmente e
depois tem que aprender a montar
completamente tudo e a utilizar eu
também tenho que aprender a usar
equipamentos de proteção equipamentos
que permitem determinar que produto
químico é questão é que estão a
enfrentar pode ser um produto muito
tóxico pode ser um produto menos tóxico
E para isso existem equipamentos e aqui
vocês podem ver que alguém que está sou
eu na realidade a
tentar utilizar o equipamento
sim mas mais importante do que isso e
vocês podem imaginar E falou Voltando a
falar sobre a parte da Síria os produtos
químicos quando são usadas as armas
químicas ficam absorvidos e ficam a
agarrados
ou aquilo que trazemos vestidos tanto é
preciso ir à luz e isso implica aprender
técnicas de descontaminação ou seja de
tirar fisicamente e ou quimicamente o
produto do fato pode ser do fato e pode
ser uma maneira muito simples para quem
estiver no quem tiver no sítio onde
tenha havido uma contaminação química e
tirar a roupa Ah eu não estou aqui a
palavra fazer um clube de strip
relacionado com o pcw mas é na realidade
a melhor coisa a fazer tira noventa
porcento da contaminação portanto se
vocês tiverem numa área contaminada a
primeira coisa a fazer é tirar tentarem
tirar o mais possível a roupa para que a
com e não fique bem contra o vosso corpo
isso é a área da preparação
também tem a área da resposta EA área da
resposta tem muito a ver com a
coordenação das Diferenças equipas que
podem ser que podem ser
participado na resposta a pedido do
estado foi atacado e para isso a ou pcw
trabalha com os diversos países treinar
que os diversos países treina também com
as nações unidas e com as agências
humanitárias que estão ligadas à
área de de do apoio humanitário e a área
de resposta em caso de um incidente que
causa vítimas ou danos ambientais e isso
é feito nesta área chamada o o choque
que é onde site operations and
coordination Center aqui é normalmente
manuseado e coordenado pela pela pela
que horas
e o que é que nós fazemos mais tentamos
fazer isso dentro da nossa área e isto é
apenas algumas fotografias a sobre o
assunto
é uma mais
e eu e eu aqui mais ou menos expliquei
fiz um bocadinho que a organização
é claro que esta organização
finalmente tem alguma visibilidade e
ganhou essa visibilidade a o ano passado
quando em outubro
recebemos o prêmio Nobel da Paz
eu gostava de vos dizer que este Prémio
Nobel da Paz foi sem dúvida me sinto mas
se vocês podem até suspeitar que eu
tenho alguma alguma interesse em dizer
isso mas mas não tanto assim o meu
trabalho era numa área importante mas
talvez não Há mais importante mas de vos
dizer que isto deve-se muito ao trabalho
Fantástico que os meus colegas têm feito
na Síria eles trabalham sob condições
extremamente adversas eles estão lá a
desde Outubro permanentemente Terra lá
em agosto quando o ataque se deu a eles
conseguiram até agora tirar oitenta e
dois por cento
e tiveram já foram raptados já foram
libertados já muitas vezes ficam retidos
no hotel outras vezes podem sair mas
eles que tem feito um belíssimo trabalho
e por isso eu acho que o mundo deve
alguma coisa e essa coisa que eles Deve
que eles deu e que teve o prazer de nos
dar foi o Prémio Nobel da Paz em 2013
conta mim eu de vos dizer que eu acho
que atingir uma grande parte do meu
sonho sou química infelizmente não eu
faço investigação apesar de gostar Ah
mas se passo mas tem descobrir soluções
que tenham impacto na melhoria da vida
das pessoas e isso para mim é importante
a e por isso e posso até dizer que me
sinto até muito muito bem Vai decida quê
Porque na realidade tive ao rei o prazer
de também ganhar um sobre 500 do prêmio
Nobel Muito obrigado a